like we never ever go hard for this they
want what you got that's all my practice
that's all about practice there has been
a second coming of Jesus Shuttlesworth
20 years to the date Lincoln High School
has once again produced the most
sought-after
high school basketball prospect Coney
Island's known for its high crime rates
and rampant drug use since mother shed
has overcome the odds this is your
moment short time way big by a boy stop
thinking about that because faith is on
another level we have faith mother said
in studio today I know you grew up in
the same neighborhood as Jesus
Shuttlesworth everyone used to watch me
at the parks and his jump shot his
crossover deffend motivated me to play
basketball faith is the future of
basketball there's nothing like her she
is not only important to basketball but
she's brought to the culture stay with
me hope she keeps her head on straight
she stays focused we need and all eyes
are on her as she decides what to do
with her future
he had a big decision to make and you
have one as well
decision for us you got Dana she got
name
I heard she might skip school and just
go to Russia the plan you gotta go to
Russia and get this money how no I mean
look at me I'm Gucci down okay big state
is one of the most dominant women's
programs out there I know we're far from
New York if you come here you're late to
set up for success by yo Boyle College
probably isn't high on your list while
we heard about your mother
you could stay close to her I see
championships in your future
professional career in less than a week
Bank will answer some schools prayers
gratitude is best for you
[Music]
see again
[Music]